back live.
Happy 5th.
Hope you've all had a
festive 4th of July.
Pretty much just worked on some AI stuff
yesterday and then called it a uh an
early night.
We did do one cool thing though.
Go grab my chat.
Stick it underneath the uh
Yeah, this is pretty cool. Like maybe
you've seen the drone light shows where
all the drones are super coordinated and
you're like, "Ah, why do you need RL?"
The thing is like those drones kind of
just have to go from point to point and
they're routed such that they don't
really have to worry about collisions at
all because you're just kind of like
rotating an object for the most part. So
nothing can collide. Uh whereas this
like there's no actual path planning
included. the drones kind of just have
to figure out how to get there from
whatever starting point without crashing
into each other. And you can actually
see them trying to like get out of each
other's ways. Now, this is not perfect.
You can see that there are still a few
places where they're a bit off, but like
this was like a two-day demo and this
just works and it trains in a couple of
minutes. They can do a lot more than
just this as well. Uh that's not what
we're going to be working on
for the most part today, though.
Today the plan is going to be to work on
my article.
So, uh, we've had just I think more than
anything I've done, I've had people
request educational materials
and you know, it's not the main thing I
do. It's actually it's really not like I
didn't start these streams to teach
people reinforcement learning and it's
actually not even my main objective now.
See, my main objective
is to advance the science, to advance
the field, right?
That's the whole shtick around here.
But it's been pretty cool to see how
many people have gotten into
reinforcement learning because of Puffer
Lib. And a lot of those people have gone
on to actually help us quite
meaningfully in our research. So, I
think uh today I'm going to spend a
little bit of time a little bit back to
that community and uh
put together a decent guide. Welcome,
Magid.
So, this is where we are at the moment
on the guide.
You're at 2200 words already.
I do always get a little bit nervous
when I write longer pieces of content
like this just because
like very often longer stuff doesn't do
as well. People have very short
attention spans. But at the very least
this is going to end up being a
very complete reference
for a lot of people. So we finished
yesterday,
and we got pretty far through the intro
ML section.
So, I think we'll finish the intro ML
section and then we'll actually start on
the RL proper today. And uh we'll see
how far I can get on this. And the
reason I'm streaming the writing of this
is so that people can give suggestions
on things I'm doing. Try not to derail
it too much, but obviously I do want
feedback and suggestions. Uh this is on
X, but this is not published yet. Magic.
I am working on
I am working on this live. So you can
see what I'm writing on my screen.
There's not really a way to do this in
the X formatter. Technically do a Google
doc thing, but uh it's really a lot
easier to do it directly in this format.
So I don't have to redo like reformat
the whole thing. I'm already going to
have to do this one like that once for
the website. So I like realistically I'm
not going to be working on like jumping
around sections too much. So, you'll
probably be able to just see the couple
paragraphs on my screen and provide
feedback on the thing I'm doing at the
moment, which will be more helpful
because like comments on like how to
improve different sections all around
know that the screen is just going to
distract me. I think you'd rather like
get feedback on one section at a time.
Okay, let me let's go through this
because I forgot what the heck I wrote
last night on this. And uh this is where
we'll start.
Becoming an effective re actually easier
than becoming a good programmer. This is
bait, but I genuinely believe that this
is true. Most researchers are bad
programmers. That's not even
controversial. Good programmers have a
much easier time becoming good
researchers
than bad uh than bad re uh than wait
than bad.
I don't know what I was smoking
yesterday, but okay.
I've become I became a good researcher
before I became a good programmer. I
wish I'd put more time into becoming a
good good programmer first. This is all
true.
This is like the most provocative thing
I can say while still being
uh strictly true
like or strictly in accordance with what
I believe which is
that's where I want to be.
Okay. Okay, so this is true. This is the
best resource that I know. It is not a
hard course.
It's a good minimum bar because if you
can't do this course, you kind of just
need to pick up a calculus textbook.
And believe me, my math sucks. So that's
not a high bar.
I've been studying a little bit of
quantum physics lately, so I've been
trying to pick back up some math, but
okay. So, I still believe that this is
true like
courses have very quickly diminishing
returns especially in ML. So kind of
take this course and you start reading
papers.
So these are the two tips that I came up
with
that are the most helpful for
understanding how to read science.
Understanding the process by which
science is done
and then not like trusting. These are
two very good things.
I only want to do three to five I think
main tips for ML because I think that's
really all you need.
What of my own experience
most useful thing I can get?
how I look to evaluate like how do you
know what to work on? I think
the question right
do you have any questions magically
things on how to learn ML things that
are confusing
if you know ML what were things that
were confusing to
are learning or don't know ML like what
are things that are I mean same question
right what are things that are confusing
these are got like these have got to be
two of the best things I can tell you
can I join Discord yeah I can jump in
Discord
you're going to have to allow me to like
focus and write paragraphs when I need
to absolutely discuss stuff in between
and that's open to everybody by the way
it's just discord.gg/puffer GG/puffer.
Uh you're free to just jump in here.
I still remember what it was like
learning ML. It was hard. But the thing
is the experience that I had is going to
be even harder than the experience that
new people have today because like the
materials just sucked back then.
Not only did the material suck, but
literally the technique sucked as well.
I don't even remember if we were using
atom yet.
I don't know. I have a pretty unique way
in which I
like the way that I look at research and
the way that I'm able to effectively
pick what to work on, I think is pretty
unique.
It's not the way that most other
researchers do it.
Like these two things, I think these are
very good tips.
Um, these are tips that
I think many researchers could give you,
but probably would be too polite to
because you kind of have to [ __ ] on the
scientific process and solutions.
Dirt, welcome.
Uh, I can't hear you.
say something.
Uh, yeah. You're just super quiet. Let
me turn this up.
I can I can I I can hear you. Okay. I
can mostly hear you. You sound like
you're super far away from a mic.
Okay. Let me see if I can Okay, let me
turn you down first so that you don't
blow out my eard drums.
Okay. Is it good now?
Little better. Yeah. Okay. I'll just
I'll turn it up on my end and hopefully
let me know if you're going to like max
your volume before you blow up my
eardrums, though. Okay. And uh I think
Larry was here.
I'm trying to remember which person
Larry was. I think he was like wanting
to start with Puffer and already was
doing RL. I'm trying to remember. I
don't know. You can jog my memory if
you're still here.
Um,
yeah. Do you have uh magic or do you
have I hope I'm saying your name right.
Not completely butchering it by the way,
but do you have stuff? You can say
magic. Magic. Okay.
physics grad with a few projects. Right.
Right. Right. Okay. Physics grad. Yeah.
We love I love when we have people in
hard sciences. Um because this is
ultimately where we want to go with
Puffer,
not RL. We actually we have two physics
grads around here. There's uh Tyler
is in the Discord and who drops in
around here as a uh he's currently a
physics postoc.
Um,
yeah,
we definitely want to do more stuff with
hard science. Ultimately, where I want
to go with Puffer is optimizing like
complicated real world processes that
just don't fit with LLMs and other of
these big models and where we can do
like high perf and all that. Like I want
to see if we can really push forward
hard science and hard tech.
LM stuff. Yeah.
And people don't really realize it. So
that is my plan. And if you have ideas,
I will be very happy to entertain them.
Ma, you wanted to share some of your
experience with uh ML. You said any
ideas for me for this article? Yeah, I
think uh before that I think if I give
some
introduction about myself like
background that I have. Sure.
you know like I'm coming from you know
the industry I work for software
development
you know
I mean I know programming well I know
different languages JavaNet
you know any web programming or back end
programming and I know that so what
happened you know
I have few problems by But I I actually
don't know how can I solve that using
you know regular
I mean we can we can solve a lot of
things using you know regular
programming conditional
way right
but you know I was interested to learn
AI ML
I try to learn
little bit of deep learning and a basic
projects but you know I was not kind of
uh feeling well that probably this is
not an uh exact thing that I should
learn then I found
which is you know I was super interested
like how things are work the fundamental
things of ar
so you know I I try maybe it's it's been
four five months I I'm studying with
and you know their different libraries
but I was kind of stuck at some point
yeah you know I I'm not able to solve
few specific problem but I cannot even
run on my machine that's how frustrated
I was yeah I I am aware I used I had to
deal with it for a while okay did you do
something like 231N
did you do something like 231N or like a
general deep learning course or you just
coming into RL just without anything in
AI?
No, no, I I know little bit of how how
to build
not that deep, you know, like could you
write could you write a basic autograd?
Yes. Yeah. Okay. If you could write a
basic autograd then you have at least
something. Have you read like at least
some number of academic papers?
So I I don't have like Yeah, I did
couple of them but you know I do not
understand few of them are goes over my
head. Okay. Yeah. So that's okay. I I
got you now. I So I didn't know where
you are from that. Um
you do have to read papers in AI. It's
not just for the researcher. Like if
you're an AI you have to read some
papers like at least some. Uh and it it
is hard and it gets easier. This is
actually this right here is exactly
intended to help with this
because one thing that I feel about
paper
for some reason like
I I I do I do read couple of uh papers
but I feel like
it's I mean on on paper for some reason
researcher they don't want to use simple
words and uh this is if you use
complicated word that means your paper
is great. If it is not if it if you use
simple word that means it's a budget.
Okay. Read read have you read this
paragraph?
Oh I mean the X
the paragraph that is on my screen right
now. Have you read this paragraph?
What? Excretion.
This is uh
this is an article, Larry.
Yeah.
Does Does this paragraph help Magic?
We
It's an article, not a tweet. It's
helped to Yeah. help to kind of uh how
should I prepare myself when I kind of
approach a paper? So this article is
very dense like it's not hard to read
but like everything in this article like
it is meant to be very dense. So like if
you read this paragraph a couple times
and you really think about this
a lot of things in science will be a lot
clearer including how to read papers.
Yeah. No, that's that's that's actually
true. I think true for everybody. It's
not not just wants to learn RL. It's
kind of a general
like this is a general comment on
science but it's particularly true in
AI.
So it's it is literally the case that
like yes very often a lot of these
papers are way simpler than they appear
and that is by design.
This is why it is by design
and understanding that should help you
figure out understanding that should
help you.
Yeah. So I was even when I open any
paper you know there ideal is good but
when I go you know beyond abstract I was
kind of a lost on every time takes time
100%
like if you look at this for instance
this the original imageet paper
let's do like uh resnet
at GPU time. Literally, that is what
happens. That's actually in a nutshell
why RL is such a mess.
Like this is the ResNet paper.
This paper could probably be like two
pages.
This is like one of the most fundamental
papers.
But pretty much this is true of a lot of
things where like the key idea of this
is a few sentences
and then like maybe like a few pages of
experiments and details.
Instead, this is an eight-page very
dense paper with an additional
three pages of appendices.
We did some dot products and sketch
connections. Yeah,
this is why I no longer write papers, by
the way, because writing papers in this
style is just soul crushingly painful to
me.
when I can write more way more casually,
way more succinctly, and way more
precisely like this.
Okay,
let me think if there's a sentence or
two I can add to this that would help
you.
Um so let me let me share of experience
like
when I go through any
paper like nobody told me like how to
approach that paper what was what should
our expectation when I read that paper
you know and the paper you mentioned is
like those are all pre-selected or you
know for a who want to start
you know they shouldn't do all the paper
they should look some sort of sective
paper and we should kind of
I will give you a list for reinforcement
learning
yeah yeah for summary and thing like do
not expect other than these things from
this paper just understand understand
the fundamentals understand the
implementation that's it some of the so
the papers that I suggest
because it is such a short list um you
actually probably want to understand
most of the things in the papers that I
suggest because I don't tend to suggest
[ __ ] papers that are like super
padded um but it's a very short list
like for instance the open AI5 paper the
Dota paper is really long but like
there's a huge amount of value in
understanding that paper like I'd take
that I would take that paper over like a
randomly selected set of a 100 RL papers
say all of which have a decent number of
citations. I still take the open AI5
paper
right and so you know what approach I I
took on that time when I don't
understand so I what I did I basically
upload that paper into
uh Google notebook
and that's kind of simplified me the
overall expectation and so you can do
that but like Google notebook book I
assume is LLM.
Yeah. So, language models are really
stupid is the thing. And
you actually do need to like it's hard,
but you do need to actually learn how to
extract truth out of papers. It is a
very important skill. It is very hard. I
remember this. I started doing this when
I was 16. And let me tell you, it was a
hell of a lot harder back then. Um, but
you can learn it.
This is why this is why like when I said
how to the point is like when I give
people this RL guide, I drip feed it to
you. So like you don't have to do this
before you do anything in reinforcement
learning, right?
It is something that you do need to do
as you improve.
I can get people started without reading
any papers.
But you do need to do this to improve.
Yeah, we need to have to read paper.
It's it is mandatory. It is actually
mandatory.
Get this from Larry
Oh yeah, I forgot three blue, one brown.
I actually haven't seen any of his
videos really. People speak very highly
of them.
this is kind of a explainer video, I
guess. Yeah. And like this guy is this
guy is not like a shill. This guy is
like actually a mathematician who
usually gets stuff right.
I don't know. I don't really watch like
a lot of technical content except
courses. I don't really watch a lot of
technical content in my uh in my spare
time.
facts. Oh yeah,
it's it's not exactly that reason,
Larry. It's the fact that like
distilling
uh actually distilling papers into what
matters, what matters, what is true,
what is probably true, what makes sense
but may or may not be true. Like that is
a skill and LLMs are bad at it. Uh and
if LLMs were good at it, then they could
probably do research on their own
effectively. Yeah, I think
Apple just uh published a paper like
about LMS and they said LM is about
illusion the model.
Yeah. I So, basically, here's the thing,
and I will say this once because it's
like we banned this spot. Like,
regardless of your views on how fast you
think LLMs will improve,
it's kind of stupid to let it influence
how you learn things in any way, shape,
or form because like
if you think, oh, the LM is going to be
able to distill the paper and like
suggest the topics. Oh, the LM is going
to be able to code the experiments. Oh,
the LM's going to be able to like
validate results. Okay, you're just
saying that you think AGI is happening
next year and that all of like all human
talent will be irrelevant. So like at
that point, you may as well not be doing
any of this. Go lie on a beach
somewhere, right? So like I if you
actually think that your agency matters
at all, you should still learn these
things and you should learn them at a
deep level
because if you don't learn them at a
deep level and you just learn things
surface level
then you have no you're not going to be
able to provide any value compared to
people who actually do learn these
things correctly.
This is how I view a lot of things.
Hey, welcome.
Okay.
Uh, is there something I can add on
this?
It's difficult to distill that
discussion a couple of sentences.
Well, I think I can make this part of
the next section. I think is going to be
What do I title this? It's kind of the
way that I view research or the way that
I choose problems
or
if someone's understand levels
uh that is not true Almas because MIT
and Stanford I I did my undergrad at
Stanford and I did my PhD at MIT and
both of them have courses available
fulllength courses available for free
online that are the exact same courses
that I took
and I'm going to let you in on a little
secret course work is like less than 10%
of my background of like what actually
makes me able to do what I do. It's
important and learning the fundamentals
quickly uh does give you a leg up,
Your time you have to put in is
non-negotiable. It's true. Now, Larry, I
do think that like we could
substantially bring down the time that
is required to learn a lot of these
things. Uh, it's still going to take
time and effort, but like for instance,
I probably could have shaved five years
of like five blunder years of terrible
programming off if like I actually had
somebody to discuss things with who was
actually good at what they did. Um,
programming is terribly taught.
You're taught to solve problems in just
about the worst way imaginable and it
gets ingrained very quickly and you
actually end up having to spend years
unlearning stuff.
That's my perspective.
Like overjectoriented everything is
awful, awful, awful, awful.
Literally one screw up in my systems
course. One screw-up in my systems
course um prevented me from touching
systems dev for almost a decade. You
know what that screw-up was? They didn't
tell us what an address sanitizer was or
even that they existed.
Writing C without an address sanitizer
sucks. And it really put me off of
low-level programming in general.
The rest of the courses actually were
very very bad. Stanford's uh systems
courses are terrible. Um
but like that in particular was I think
the worst screw up of all of them.
No Russians. Russian since I'm from past
Soviet country. It's a good source. ML
Yandex also working with best
university.
Well, if it's in Russian then that's not
going to help too much of my audience.
But if you can do that then yeah good
for you.
No, one thing I I I also have like I
also face some of problem because you
know when someone tried to learn or any
particular field like AI or deep
learning or data science or any any
other fields
basically we think
if I learn what I'll become
like let's say I'm investing 2 3 years
four years into particular technology or
uh particular carrier what I I'll I'll
become next. So
I I think for specific to RL we don't
have
that kind of a vision in particularly
for a beginner like
if I know you are trying to learn RL but
learning RL what you can do what you can
do with RL without you know playing
games.
Yeah, I mean most of the tutorial or
blogs everybody talks about the games
but nobody talks about the real world
problem. Yeah. So that is also one of
the main reason that people
are kind of unsure like they are not
confident to be honest. Yeah. I need to
motivate this stuff to be fair. And also
Almas we do have right here this quick
start guide. This thing is littered with
references. I'm working on it. The
document I'm working on is a sequel to
this, but all of this is still up to
date. It's just shorter than the thing
I'm making now. Um, this is on
puffer.ai. It's on the blog. So, yeah,
the thing is that like reinforcement
learning has been applied in a a few
different very interesting use cases,
right? Um, outside of games. We use
games a lot because they're
interpretable in research, but like RL
is also just a less mature area of AI in
general than vision or language
processing, right? Um,
so it's like what if you understand the
tech, there are things about it that
very clearly make it uh seem like this
is going to be something useful down the
line. But a lot of the work in RL, it's
like there aren't just like applied RL
jobs like there are applied vision jobs,
right? Like technically there are a few
jobs that say that they're applied RL,
but they mostly don't work. Um,
and that's just because it's a less
mature area. So
the bet that I have on RL right is
because very clearly it can solve hard
problems and we have seen the pace of
progress pick up in the last year with
all of the stuff I'm doing with Puffer
that this is going to be a very widely
applicable
area and it's going to be applicable
mostly to a lot of just unintuitive
optimization processes that are
scattered all throughout different
industries. So, it's going to have uh
very broad reaching effects. Not going
to be like a chatbot that you just ask
stuff. It's going to be like embedded
into a lot of hard tech.
That is uh that is my view on it. But
like it's not here now because the thing
is that it's not a mature it's not as
mature area, right? You're looking at a
branch that is mostly active research
that is being used by like largely
technical companies that have their own
scientists. Right.
And and if we talk about like f future
opportunities like
well if you learn deep learning if you
learn deep learning like how long do you
think it would take me to go be like as
good as at uh as good at language model
work as I am now at RL? It would take me
a few months. It's all the same,
right?
I could go I can work in any area of
deep learning that I like. It will take
me a few months to get up to speed.
And probably you know so what make me
come to in particularly why I choose if
I talk about myself why I prefer other
industry compared to you know
Why I choose basic if if you know people
already seeing this up until till now
every
um real world application that we have
you know maybe you know 90% or 97% or
99%. They are all rulebased application
not like a
you know
AIdriven or you know general purpose
application. If if if we think about the
when we it comes to general purpose then
comes into our fundamental because
in real world that application needs to
adapt and adapt such a way so that it
can you know be in the environment under
the
so I think uh in next 5 10 years there
will be huge opportunity for you know
quite Well, another big thing is just
like
it's an area of deep learning that one
teaches you a lot of technical skills
and two you can actually do it at home.
Like you can't go train GPT4 at home.
It's just not going to happen.
Uh Elma says, "Wait, by the way, it's
what PC you're using. I see you have
Linux. What about specs?" So, behind me
I have
uh like a dozen different PCs sitting on
the racks.
Uh the one that I have right here is
just a it's a high-end Main Gear box
with a 4090 in it.
If you just want something for
reinforcement learning, uh, you need to
get like something that has a good GPU
of some variety. It doesn't need to have
a huge amount of memory.
4090s are really nice. I don't know how
fast a 5080 is by comparison, but some
good chip. And then you also want to
ideally get you want to get a good
multi-core CPU.
Like I have a 9950X. I think that's the
best desktop chip you can get at the
moment for this. Uh the Intel chips I've
had a bunch of problems with and they're
architecturally a little bit wonky, but
they still work.
But yeah, like you ideally you want to
get like a 16 core chip.
It's not free, right? Like it's just a
heck of a lot cheaper than everything
else. You can also you can rent stuff
like if you go on like Vast
You can rent 4090s for 34 cents an hour,
sometimes lower.
I have 1590.
There's one of the machines back there
that's a test machine that's a 5090.
It's substantially faster for some
problems and not all that much faster
than a 4090 for others.
I was going to buy more and I think I
still am, but uh I did. I just bought
two tiny boxes. So that's plus 12 4090s.
We now have a total of 20 4090s for
puffer.
you think about finance world bots will
alter the quants I do a little bit of
work in finance that I can't really talk
any details about um
when do you think
and there already are bots like
everywhere in finance right just a
question of like at what scale and such.
I would hope it's not just people like
letting LLM run trades on the market
though. That's probably going to just
lose a ton of money.
Okay, I got to actually write on this,
right? The point of streaming this is so
that we discuss this and so that I write
it effectively. There are definitely
people doing that. Yeah, but they're def
like there people doing all sorts of
stupid things.
I hate the idea of any human effort
being wasted on fan art. Yeah, like
there are way more interesting problems.
I agree. I would like, you know, to
solve disease and superconductivity
and material science and all sorts of
things.
Let's let's add right here. How do I let
me see how I want to frame this though?
I've sort of been thinking about this
while I've been chatting. Um,
I don't want to say research taste
because
it's like the massive midwit topic on uh
X at the moment
cuz it's not taste. That's not what it
is. Not a good word for it.
It's really it's about it's building
intuition about research what it is.
No, you're good. It's uh it's just like
typos that happen when editing, right?
Like you changed the part of a sentence
and now something later on that was uh
that was plural becomes singular, etc.,
etc.
So
when when should I I mean on which stage
I should see the papers beginning or
after? You should probably start reading
them. words like you should have read a
few papers by the time that you finish
something of the level of CS231N
and then pretty much as you are trying
to improve methods or as you are trying
to improve your understanding of any
specific area you should be reading a
few papers over time um
it's a lot earlier than you think I
would say like literally there were zero
courses in uh deep learning when I
started. So my first experience with
deep learning at the age of 16
uh was just reading papers.
I had like
basic I think I had like basic single
variable calculus and linear algebra and
that was it. That's all I knew and like
basic programming. Which year it is? It
was what?
Which year it was? Like I was like 16.
That's halfway through high school.
2016.
Oh, which year was this? Uh, no. This
would have been like 20 probably 2013 or
14.
Oh, that's that's pretty
Yeah. Yeah. I've been doing this a
while.
How long you streaming for? I'm going to
go get stuck into Puffer and try out the
environments
probably until a bit before 6. I'm going
to dinner with my family for a Fourth of
July thing July thing. It's the day
after for some reason.
I need to make this paragraph good. This
is not
I don't like the way this is going right
at the moment.
Can can we um like before going into
like more details um can we kind of uh
generate like the steps step by step uh
you know a level category
let's say uh you know doing the the
course that you mentioned is let's Send
for one step. Second is you have to read
paper. Second step. What's the third?
What's the third?
Yeah, that's it. Yeah, third is you know
pick a
easy to understandable.
That's it. There no more steps properly
for AI in general. That's it. There are
no more steps. Like you do your intro
stuff, you start reading papers and
building things and you keep reading
papers and building things forever.
That's it. There's no like magic third
thing. Now for reinforcement learning
specifically, right? Like if you want
like more details on the specific area
of RL, then yes, that's going to be the
other portion of the article. I want to
finish the intro portion first, though.
I should be able to do quite quickly if
I just like it's only a couple more
paragraphs.
I just actually have to
Okay, let let me write my question to
you and then probably can um
those
Okay. So, I don't like this paragraph a
ton. I think that there's
this is not telling people enough. This
is like a very important topic.
I think it's fair to say I think it's
fair to say that this is a combination
of of validation
of validating results and pattern
matching, right?
knowledge of fundamentals,
pattern matching and validation.
Can't wait to read the whole thing. So
much good stuff in there. Yeah, I'm
working on it. Major
I have made like 15 question to you. 15
questions?
Yeah. Did you write up a doc or
something?
Yeah. Let me let me get the link. You
can link me the doc. Let me at least get
this paragraph done.
No, you can write you can you can see um
I I have those questions and I want to
know how can Let me let me see if
they're relevant. I'll look at them now
and if not I'll look at them after this
paragraph.
Okay, you can I can I'll post them
in general.
Okay. Yeah. So, you're this is all RL
specific.
So let me finish this first.
We'll ask for this.
Actually I depending on how long this
gets I could release it as two articles.
That might be better.
This is like an important point.
Like literally if you if you have too
much respect
for the scientific process, you cannot
be an effective researcher because you
will simply assume that things are true
because they're published when they're
not.
That's what the scientific method is.
So it depends because here's the thing,
Larry, right? like
there's a peer review process, right?
Yes, the scientific method itself is
about asking questions of things. But
the thing is
like
if that's all it is, then like why is
there a peer review process, right? Why
like the point of the peer review
process is to ascertain that the thing
being submitted for publication is
actually correct.
which then creates this impression that
if something is published, it's probably
correct and it's not.
See,
so yeah, trust the science is the least
scientific thing you can possibly say.
But the thing is the institutions are
set up in such a way that it suggests
that publications like have already been
reviewed by people smarter than you,
especially when you're in a new area,
right? Like, oh, this has already been
reviewed by experts in this area. No,
man. It's been like leafed through by
some overworked grad student who's like
writing some basically random comments
and calling it a day.
What are you sipping on? Uh
a seltzer that is flat because
apparently it was from yesterday which
is why I made a face.
I'll get more coffee in a second. I got
to finish this paragraph and then my
reward is more coffee.
And then they get published in nature
and you go, "Oh, wow. What a great
thing.
actually. You know what we're going to
do? I know what we're going to do.
There's way more out there than puffer
and our lib.
obviously you forgot about the page.
page limits. There are usually
appendices for that.
I honestly I don't think that people
drop ablations for page limits as much
as they drop them for time and GPU
constraints.
That you'd hate it.
Why am I laughing?
Because of this.
like if you think about actually doing
RL research that guy you'd actually be
kind of crazy to use anything else. Like
I'm not talking about LLMs like core RL
research. You'd be kind of crazy to use
anything else just because of the speed
difference alone.
they're actually explicitly not required
to uh to look at the appendices most of
the time.
conference has appendices.
Most of them do. I think at this point
most of them do have the appendices. It
does depend.
But like if you didn't have to write
that paper the way that academic papers
are supposed to be written, you actually
tried to like you could have fit a lot
of that stuff in.
Like academic writing is super bloated
and dry and boring.
Okay. To be fair, I'm probably mostly
just thinking of Nurups because that's
the big one that everyone submits to my
website.
Yeah. So that I mean that's more like
blog post walkthrough. I think if you
wanted to just like put like the core
ablations and like motivate like you
could probably fit a lot of it. All
right, spy.
That's absolutely you. Totally not.
I know you're like you're only partially
joking there. If Pokemon just ran a
thousand times faster, you wouldn't have
that problem.
to put my Delops
graphics to work.
It will actually let you at least run
Pong with that.
just found the full RL iceberg. Yeah,
that watch that video. That one's uh
that one took a lot of work and didn't
get very much attention. I think it's a
a high quality thing.
AI research is
five coding RL environments.
there,
dude.
I mean, I would it would be a snarky
retweet if anything because it's an
incredibly stupid take.
Welcome, essay.
the highest leverage thing you can do
is actually learn to code
uh
and then actually like help us build
some RL environments and turn justice.
Is this like Who is this? Is this
somebody I want to even
wait?
Oh, these dudes. Freaking Prime, man.
They have some good stuff and they have
some abysmally stupid takes.
Where's the intro thing on puffer.ai?
It's in the blog.
I got to fix a couple posts in here. But
see, there's a quick start guide.
the RPO themselves into a
I thought you'd enjoy the take.
I don't know why. I mean, it's like
like literally all of my content is
about actually understanding things
correctly.
Like you like, let me make something
clear. Like if you're typing things into
if you're just basically typing [ __ ]
into uh into whatever LLM in a loop
without actually understanding what's
going on, you have zero marginal value.
Zero. Utterly worthless.
The highest leverage thing unskilled
engineers can do is pay.
I mean, look,
the highest leverage thing you can do
for RL is kind of just to mail me some
gold bars.
And uh I I will help solve your
problems.
I will help solve your problems.
Like I'm literally making it as easy as
possible for new people to get good at
reinforcement learning. And we have a
few people who have been puffer, but
like the mainstream is still like a like
a catastrophic screw up. So for as long
as people keep doing it wrong, that's
kind of the best thing you to get me to
do it.
And for reference, we have set uh soda
on like multiple different clients uh
projects for 10k a month. So there you
go. Also star puffer lip. It helps us
out a ton.
This is like a really good piece of
advice, but it feels generic and it
doesn't feel like the strongest thing I
can tell people.
Why is X chat broken?
Uh, if you link stuff, it'll break. If
you spam messages, it'll break. If you
look at it the wrong way, it'll break.
It's not stop thinking just do it
sounds like a shippable product.
The product that we have is service
contracts
uh as well as I mean deliverables
contracts to be fair. But yeah, all our
stuff is free and companies can hire us
to help with their reinforcement
learning efforts or to solve like
problems that clearly are RL problems
for them.
They're larger though. Fix deliverables.
Why don't I like this paragraph?
It's very good advice, but it feels
generic.
But something of this form I think is
needed.
If I want to like think of the top three
things that I can tell people on
learning ML in general,
But when you say learning research, how
do you do it?
It's not quite that though, that guy.
It's not just like it's not just put in
the reps.
I'm trying to provide perspective on how
to approach that process to make it
faster and make more sense.
Our alchemy
turn money into
gold is money
about your anecdotal experience instead
of some generic story.
There's only so much I can flame
existing researchers though because
basically the evidence that I would have
to provide here
um would basically be like how I found
out that X and Y researchers are frauds.
RLD no when do you realize you developed
intuition? I mean it was a slow
continual process right from the time I
started reading papers
You ever have an aha moment
in reading papers? Not really.
I mean, Nurups is massive. So, it's fine
to have a smaller conference. I will be
going to RLC. Hey,
training. LM depend a lot on RL. Now
they do apparently
that like use a lot of RL in a specific
stage.
Uh yeah, mostly at the end.
Don't be afraid to be a contrarian, but
you better know what I'm doing. I'm
being as contrarian as possible without
saying X, Y, and Z specific research,
specific incredibly wellrespected
researchers are frauds.
See, the problem is that with doing that
is that they're very damn good at it.
Um,
yeah.
And that's not even a useful thing
because that's not what I'm trying to
tell you, right?
research comes from contrarians.
I mean, I could write about the way that
I approach problems like that. It is
pretty much I just like look for the
thing that nobody else is doing.
When do you see RL problem and determine
it's not possible with current RL
research?
Uh I mean some problems are just not
formatted well for RL, right? You can
very very easily construct problems that
are trivial for humans but like
virtually impossible for reinforcement
learning.
Okay. So, like
literally all you'd have to do is take
an image that says like to solve this
problem, enter the following code and
put a code and then the action is
entering the code. You're not going to
solve it with RL ever.
mostly problems that rely on like baked
in priors that are not learnable within
an environment itself.
How hard would it be to pre-train an LLM
with only RL? Impossible for the exact
same reason.
Just take the information theory
perspective on it, right? You're getting
a bit of information per sequence
instead of like number of bits
information of bits per sequence. Anyone
here play a chess? We have somebody in
the Discord trying to uh get us a chess
environment for RL. That's actually
something that I wanted to do is see
like how well you can do at chess with
just RL and no search.
Usually it's because there's some form
of outside knowledge
reward is scarce and requires complex
disc.
It's the thing with neural MMO, right,
is like you almost a human doesn't have
to actually have played it a bunch to
know how to play it because the visual
information is set up to be to be very
obvious, right?
You have to think about how how you
would learn the problem tabularasa. How
would you learn the problem from
scratch?
Okay, I'm spending way too long on this
intro section and I want this to be
done. So, let me let me finish this
paragraph. Enough.
is too simple to learn multiplication.
How often do you see
big policy also? Not that often. We do
have complicated problems where it makes
a difference. I'm going to have to look
more at your environment in detail. I
haven't been able to do so yet though
because you actually have a fairly like
sophisticated environment and it's going
to actually take me a fair bit of time
to go through and like validate the
method.
So I also don't know how your data is
being presented or normalized or
anything like that. Like if you actually
trace through what has to be done to
solve your task and the rewards given,
does it seem like something that could
be learned via curriculum or
exploration?
Okay,
let's see if there's anything in here.
I mean then that tells you something,
right?
If you supervise the problem and you're
getting about the same result, that
should tell you something. Been
following you and watching streams for
three months now. Stealth watching,
working my way up ML. Haven't reached RL
yet. And it's coded. Work ethic is
admirable. Oh man, this is considered
lazy for me this week
for these streams. You got it, man. I
will uh I'll be releasing this guide
soon for beginners. you should
absolutely do some ML fundamentals
first. Um, as in the guide here, I it's
like one course worth of information, I
think, like one course worth of
information in fundamentals of ML and
then you can do RL. We've literally had
brand new programmers do like start
straight with reinforcement learning
though. So, if that motivates you,
that's cool, too.
I generally suggest new people spend 20%
of their time on formal content and like
80% of their time building stuff to
learn.
Puffer Pokemon on puffer 3 trying to see
SPS fix compile info and state handler.
Cool.
What are you referring to, doctor? And
one second. Let me use the restroom real
quick.
lazy week is more
Oh man, it's Yeah, if I work like a 40
or a 50 hour week, that's like pretty
lazy.
when I'm like actually well-rested and
have like a cool project to work on, you
know, I can pull like an 80 or a 90 and
basically you can just solve like
ridiculous things in like one week uh
one productive week, but you can't do it
constantly.
Ironically, I'm least productive for uh
conference things. Like, I have to I got
to spend a day cleaning up and uh my
camera ready for RLC. I'll probably just
do it on stream. I don't care. And it's
like I'm just I don't want to do it.
Like mentally, I just can't force myself
to do boring stuff.
500 to 1k lower. Yeah. So, there's one
thing I did do that guy. Um, we did
somewhat change the way vectorization
works a bit.
might want to like triple buffer instead
of double buffer if you're doing that.
Multiplication is a convolution
of one multi- number
over the digit dimension.
somebody will have to explain this cuz I
don't I don't think it is
Don't think it is. I don't know.
papers like RL graph
going to get the computational graph I
haven't seen that
Okay, just based on this, I can tell you
this is slow as hell.
the heck
I don't know
digit multip phrasing is convolution
using FFTs
well you can't then you have to learn
the FFT
Okay, let me go through this and see
see how I like this as a intro to ML.
The programming one is way longer.
But I think honestly like
how much more advice do I have than this
for
ML?
Buffer is 10% slower. So that guy you
might have to
you might have to adjust
um the vectorization a little bit
because
well I mean like the vectorization
settings because basically
if it's assuming it's the environment
that is slower which you should time um
it's the thing is that we were doing
like a full endpool before and now we're
basically doing the zero copy mode by
default where you get blocks you go like
one block then the next block then the
next block. So it's going to be better
if you do like triple buffered instead
of double buffered for instance uh for
this setting.
Uh and also keep in mind that the
learning should be more efficient
because
you're uh you're no longer like wasting
time on low value samples and like
screwing up your policy with lowv value
samples. It should learn better.
We haven't figured out real time
training yet. It's not that we haven't
figured out real time training. it's
that it fundamentally doesn't make sense
like at least not from a not from like a
a newly instantiated model. It doesn't
make sense. You're doing trajectory
filtering in default puffer all. Yes, we
are doing trajectory filtering by
default. We're doing puffer advantage by
default. We are doing muon by default.
All the advancements are just in there
like by default for you to use.
Let's go through this and see if this
makes sense. Still using Adam. Stop that
[ __ ] Better. You're like, you're
trolling if you're using Adam.
You're straight trolling. That was like
one of the biggest advancements.
hidden config still all over the place.
What do you mean hidden config still all
over the place? There's one there's like
one config, right? Like the default
config just has all the parameters
and d-help will list all of them.
I have to read your code to understand
the config.
By read the code, do you mean read the
read the config file or like the names
are not explicit
I haven't ported to your config style.
I'm still using my own.
I had to dig through puffer to
understand the atom config.
So, you do have to read the any files
and um I mean it's
you are sort of meant to just use the
any files. You can load stuff into a
dictionary if you really want to, but
then that's kind of like on you. Um
again, like do you need
are you looking for more than a list of
names? Because like the atom parameters
are like atom beta 1 atom beta 2 atom
epsilon or whatever right
and they are listed you don't have to
read the code right like if you just run
d-help
it will list them for you
in a way that is always up to date and
that can't get out of sync.
exactly what I'm looking for. I'm not
using your version of main. I need my
modified personal train. Okay. So when
you pip install it, you should still get
the puffer trainer and that help will
still tell you what's in there
and just run like puffer train puffer
breakout for instance
d-help.
Why do we live when there's a star?
I managed to miss some things. I come
from neuroscience background and
real-time learning sounds like a
necessity actually training like the
brain. So, okay, let me explain this
real quick. So, the reason this doesn't
make sense is that the human brain is
not an untrained neural network, right?
The human brain has a ton of priors
baked in and a heck of a lot more of
them that you get uh like general priors
that you get early in development,
right? So, when you when you sit down to
try to play Breakout, for instance, you
already know how to play the game
without having ever played it.
It's obvious. It's designed to be
intuitive and obvious.
Not obvious or intuitive to the agent.
So if you want a better analog that
makes it obvious that real time learning
is not possible, we can screw up all the
assets and like make a total mess out of
the data. And heck, we don't even have
to present it in pixels. We can just
present it to you as a block of numbers
and then you try to play the game.
That's how the RL agent sees it.
making more progress to ML than
neuroscience.
Yeah,
turns out it's nice when you can
actually like fully observe the system
you're working with.
Okay, I think that this is like a good
this is a lot of good advice here.
I don't know the extent to which
people will be able to internalize it
because like appreciating this stuff
requires just spending a bunch of time
in research.
I think that this will help. I think
that if I if I have three paragraphs
basically that all revolve around the
idea of
Actually,
or else that it's modeled after the way
the brain works. In general, you should
assume that anything in ML that is
modeled off of the way the brain works
is very very loosely so and it's mostly
modeled off of empirical results.
Okay, I think I'm happy with this these
paragraphs.
about reason.
I think just saying look for errors.
All I have to do is swap this sentence
down to
Let me see how this paragraph works now.
And if so, I think we can move on to the
rest of this
Let me see what I missed here.
Tactics strategy goal
from bio inpired agents
biolas existed way before I'm LML.
Yeah. Uh
I just finished training. Going to just
eval enjoy the stream. Thanks for great.
Yeah, thanks for dropping by.
Oh, hey, we have a fair few people
watching this. So, I'm going to start on
the RL specific portion of this in just
a second here.
So, this is what 10 pages, probably nine
with the notes at the bottom.
No, like 10 pages.
Okay. So, we've got like a 10page
article
and it's
maybe six, no, five or six on
programming.
Then it's really only like two or three
pages on ML.
And I think that this is
I think that this is the information I
want to present.
this is probably the most valuable
piece of information that I could give
myself
because like I think when I started
research
I think that I started thinking about
like okay you know what is here okay
these are the papers that have been done
this is the stuff that's been done let
me pattern match and figure out what I
can do based on this but I didn't take
into account that a lot of the work is
just wrong
so you can't really make progress when
you hold in your head many mutually
incompatible results without realizing
it
so I think that this is a fundamentally
better way of approaching research.
This would have been useful to me.
Hang on. Let me go check on one thing.
My parents are at the window for some
reason. I'll uh they're visiting. I
don't know what they're doing. I'll be
right back. Walk around a minute because
I just wrote a whole bunch of stuff. And
then we will start on the RL guide. And
uh any feedback you guys have, any stuff
that you want to uh see included, please
write it all down. Comment it here. And
then uh this this is the reason I'm
streaming this is so I can get feedback
on what you guys want to see and what
questions you have.
Time to write the RL section. I want a
puffer plushy. You and me both.
We can get uh we can get merch once we
get
I don't know nine figures of revenue or
some whatever.
If the puffer is successful, we can make
puffer plushies.
Let's go grab all the content from the
RL guide.
I'm going to do a little bit of thinking
out loud on this. So,
there are kind of two parts to this,
right?
Like this type of thing.
This is the ultra practical.
The like ultra ultra practical
version of what I could cover here.
How do I implement an environment?
Designing rewards is like fair
networks. How to tune it.
Bug hunting.
Benchmarks.
Let me look at my existing quick start
guide as a reference.
See where I want to depart from there.
So I do uh
what is RL
covered
like a bunch of common terms.
I kind of just shotgun all the terms at
you
and I give these like hiffy this is how
to understand this terms.
Man, this is actually a really good
guide to try to beat.
People want more than this though. So
let me think.
I mean, if I think about it,
I kind of just wrote something this
style
for programming in ML, didn't I?
Like that piece that I wrote compliments
this piece.
The bar is higher than I thought. I set
my own bar pretty high.
I have to understand better, I think,
where people are getting confused and
what the limitations are.
What have I given people here?
I've given people common terms and how
to think about them.
A lot of general perspective that's very
valuable, but it's going to be
it's going to be a lot to process for
newcomers.
It's the fact that this is not threaded
cleanly enough into
like actually showing you how to build
stuff, right?
I have this quick start guide and I have
the docs
and there's somehow there's a gap
between those two Thanks.
and it makes sense that I would do this
because I wrote the other one so like
this is the style which I write off.
This could be an ML quick start,
the programming quick start.
Yeah. So, if I think of what I've
written so far is just like
and then I think of the docs
as taking you through how to build
stuff.
Yeah. Like
on one hand, you have a relatively
simple tutorial that shows you how to
build something
a new area.
And on the other hand, you have a lot of
really good general advice for the same
area.
A lot of really good general advice for
this area,
but then you don't really know how to
having built a simple thing. How do you
use all this advice to do much more
complicated stuff?
do this, do this, do this, do this, do
this.
makes sense. learning how to like
I can't really assume that people just
know how to teach themselves things,
right? That is also
that itself is a very difficult to learn
skill.
We're not writing a blog on how to teach
yourself thing. That's too meta.
I mean the the best one of the best
talks I've ever seen
was on it was on game design
was on how to build tutorials
and it was just a one-s sentence
explanation. It's teach gradually
through experience. It
teach gradually through experience.
stuff like this.
This needs to exist because some of this
I can't teach you. I can't teach you
gradually through experience because you
don't really need to like you shouldn't
really experience it. You kind of just
need to know that it exists.
Other things I can teach here.
I can definitely make more concrete like
the level of projects and order you
should take them Come on.
But that's not I don't think that's
enough
because the thing is like
this is all
all This stuff is like supporting
knowledge around fundamentals.
Reading a blog is not experienced
problem.
I could do
thing implement this thing. Implement
this thing implement this.
The problem is a lot of these things are
like I can't do PO go implement PO right
I didn't think it would be this
difficult actually.
I kind of figured that I would come back
to this and it would just be like kind
of mediocre. This is really good
content. It's the presentation of the
content I think that's a problem.
I'm really having a tough time actually
figuring out how we so like so the core
advice
right the core advice comes down to
build RL environments
spend some fraction of your time reading
papers
And then here's a blog post to tell you
how to think about a lot of the things
you're building
as well as the papers you're reading.
But somehow something's getting lost in
that
if you are contributed to speedruns of a
few few simple environments
already solved it would be helpful.
Yeah, but like so how do I get from
there to helping people understand this
stuff, right? Because I literally all I
do is I run puffer sweep
on some environments and like hey look
now we have some parameters so that when
you press train it trains fast
like how to use puffer lib basics of how
to use puffer lib are the docs right
that's not how to learn reinforcement
learning
Like the key is that Puffer Lib lets you
actually do reinforcement learning
rather quickly while you're still
learning some of the basics, which not a
thing that you used to be able to do.
Like you can build you can basically
build an environment.
You can
fix like some common error classes
If I view this existing thing which
maybe I make some improvements to this,
right? If I view this as like the
general glossery
perspective and stuff,
what does this need as a what does this
need for glue? Right.
Well, we could use some very small
amount of math
producing
policy gradients, I suppose.
what exactly you're trying to teach
people. I'm trying to do an updated uh
reinforcement learning guide,
the reinforcement learning as a whole.
So, what I basically have here, right,
is I have my old RL quick start guide,
which upon looking at the information in
here is very, very good and is still all
up to date.
and this was by request because normally
I wouldn't write something like
I wouldn't write stuff for the real
fundamentals like this but I wrote a
programming like guide and I wrote an ML
guide general ML general programming
I could have do this, understand this,
right? Like do this, understand that.
So I could say
you know make a simple environment
understand
these like these common classes of
errors. Okay read this paper understand
this about the paper and about ML and I
could do that.
That's probably the thing that's
missing.
People
would appreciate a little step-by-step
guide.
There is a there is a step-by-step guide
for a very simple environment, right?
Here's a very very simple environment
written in Python.
Okay, so there are two different things
here, right? One of these is like, hey,
can you make some like clearer content
on puffer lib?
And another one is, can we have clearer
content on RL?
But I think that the thing that's
probably missing here
is like how do I write a puffer n? It
should be completely obvious if you
already know other things in RL and the
thing is you don't.
So it's like for instance if you know
how Jim does its environments
which if you're in RL at all you do then
like the puffer end format's pretty
obvious from that
cuz it's like just that with all the
slow parts chopped off.
It's pretty helpful, but most people
ask,
I guess.
Do I want to try to do this in isolation
though is the thing
So let's say that I expand this guide.
Okay,
let's say that I expand this guide and I
add it's really only a few paragraphs,
right? to just essentially explain some
of the things that is are in the
comments of the files on how an
environment is structured.
The problem formulation and problem
solving for RL, right?
That's different from teaching people
puffer.
Okay. So, let's say that I update this
guide.
You know, I kind of like the idea of
having a few different articles,
right, as resources and then having a
glue article where like this is how to
learn reinforcement learning. It's like
are you new to programming in ML? Okay,
go read this article and like do this,
this, and this. All right. Are you new
like cool, you've done that or you're
like you know how to program? Cool. Uh
you want to like you want to learn
reinforcement learning. You're going to
start by writing a very basic puffer
environment to get just a feel for
things. And I link you to a revised
version of this article right here or
this doc right here which could be an
article. Okay?
And that uh and the revised version will
include the things that you guys are
asking for.
Just problem formulation plus puffer.
It's a lot of stuff.
any plans to make it easy for people who
just want to import instead of cloning.
Not sure if it's been done yet. You can
there's uh there's a demo on this as
well.
Buffer importable.
Yeah. The problem is that if you want to
like make your own environment, right,
you have to compile it and like it's
annoying as hell to compile like C
extensions for Python unless you're
going to hook into the tooling of an
existing package. Puffer li.
So you can absolutely use puffer liib.
You can use our trainer on other stuff,
but if you want to build your own
environment, it's still easiest to clone
it for the sole reason that you have to
like you have to compile it somehow.
Okay, let's say that I'm going to start
writing a little bit on the article.
I'm going to update the docs for the
tutorial to include because like the
thing that you're asking for for like uh
the step function and that stuff that's
like two paragraphs. I can totally add
that.
Okay, I actually have some good ideas
now on how we can do this. Use the
restroom real quick and then we will uh
we'll do this.
Weird Python multipprocessing seg fault
when sweeping.
Uh it's possible that your environment
has a seg fault in it.
Usually it's that your that your uh your
environment has a rare seg.
Yeah, you can compile with it's a little
tricky, but you can compile with debug
equals true. Ideally, like what you
should do is you should try to find a
set of hypers or something that actually
reproduces this bug. If you can get a
single experiment where it happens
within a few minutes consistently,
you can compile uh puffer lib with debug
equals true and um you can actually get
stack traces
You can actually get where this egg
fault
Okay.
Go here.
Two billion steps. Lovely.
take get rid of this.
Make absolutely sure this is saved
though. Hang on.
that we now have this.
It's okay words. Good length.
Hey Spencer, we got um
we got the general purpose article. We
got a very good draft of this done.
This is 2k words
programming and ML and I'm starting on
the main article now. And I the hardest
thing and I spent a lot of time on this
is figuring out the format and like how
I wanted to present information.
I think I figured it out. Like all these
other articles I have, they're like
glosseries and like tips and general
advice and such. And I like I think I
what I want to do is I want to have a
main article that says do this, do this,
do this, do this, do this, do this. Now
you know RL and it's going to reference
all the other stuff that I've done. So,
I actually don't really need to rewrite
my old RL quick start guide as much as I
need to reference it and get you to do
things around it.
What effect does a good sweep have
versus arbitrarily picking
hyperparameters? Well, it depends
whether you want your uh your training
to actually work or not.
target audiences to bring in
uh new contributors,
new just generally folks interested in
reinforcement learning, bigger audience
in general. Uh yeah, it's it's mostly
just to grow Puffer LIIB as a platform
and and everything that we do.
So hopefully these do pretty well. We'll
see. the uh the pedibyte article did
incredibly well and uh we got multiple
new leads uh out of that on the business
side as well as quite a bit of interest
on X.
What's a good counterpart to squared
that would be super easy for someone to
build?
I could probably do it more simply to be
fair now.
binding vest step bind vec render vec
close. Should these always be called in
the class that inherits from
pufferpufferm
toc training speed up? So um those are
the hooks into the C library. You'll
notice that there's not really any logic
in the uh the Python files because the
actual logic is in C.
So you have to call the logic from C
somehow.
You make sure that this gives them
enough information like the readers
enough information to like
When you make a new M, do you start with
a certain template? Dur maybe ocean/
template. Yes, that is literally what it
is for.
Copy paste that and then just change all
the templates to your end name.
in the uh the quick start guide as well.
I mean, not the quick start guide,
that's in the docs as well.
thing with this. Let me see what else I
want to give people at this stage. Uh
before you write another environment.
Okay, actually I know what I'm going to
do.
I give them target or convert. Give them
target.
Yeah. So they just see a normalized
distance to everyone.
Where the hell do I give them reward?
Oh, here it is. Update goals.
any other references I need to give
people at this point.
common screw-ups. Do I have the common
screw-ups in?
I'm going to just add
common screw-ups.
I'm just going to make sure I do that in
the blog.
Yeah. I'm going to do wrong horizon to
blog.
So, we'll just do do
long horizon
box. Uh
PO have generalized advantage estimation
as a description in there or is it
separate?
Really big fan of poper. Good work.
Thank you very much. I'm working on a
guide for beginners at the moment.
More of a comprehensive reinforcement
learning guide.
They don't even have uh J in here, do
they?
What software using to write this? It's
just an X article.
Yeah, they don't even have it in here,
do they?
I got to link both papers.
really liked Lillian's blog for a
beginner's guide to RL. Oh, yeah.
Ah,
this is too much math.
Yeah, this is way too much math for
this.
Yeah. No, this is this is not what I
would suggest. This is way way too much
math for this.
Yeah, but you don't The thing is you
don't need this much
and this is not actually like useful
math. Like honestly, one of the best
things you can do in RL is completely
ignore this MDP formulation every of
everything. It's dated and irrelevant.
Bellman like kind of don't really need
to know this up front. Honestly, the
most important thing is
even covered here.
Yeah, Carpath I think Carpathy's blog is
way better than this. But yeah, this is
the important bit here. the policy
gradient theorem.
Puffernet.h looks powerful but
intimidating.
Okay, so Tim Puffernet is literally just
for our web demos.
It's not actually used for training.
It's just so that we can put our tiny
neural netset on the web because it's C.
So it compiles to WSOM.
Uh the the blog that I'm going to
recommend over this is Carpathy's old um
Carpathy's old policy gradient blog by
far
Pong the pixels. Yeah, I'm writing this
all up now. And by the way, this is
actually in my current guide. It's just
not in this nice form, but I'm like I'm
kind of redoing
this real?
What do you mean is this real? Mike,
how's it going?
Tell us the secret to GPT5.
Uh so what they did is they stuffed Sam
Alman into a box and uh what they did is
they overclocked him dramatically. So
whenever you're querying GPT5, you're
actually just asking a question directly
to turbo mode Sam Alman and he answers
it personally.
Where's your current guide? It's on
puffer.ai and it's also on X.
We have a blog on puffer.ai. I got to
fix the top couple articles on there. Uh
some formatting issues lately, but it's
on there. It's also an X
mainly locked in. when you're typing
fast
without smiling.
I mean, this is kind of chill day. I'm
just writing some stuff and normally
building things,
guys. Actually, oh, that was uh that was
a different startup. Like, that wasn't a
different company that was actually
doing that. I think that's happened a
couple times.
That's like I think that's actually
happened a couple of times.
I mean it's basically like a therronos
but for AI, right? Kind of the
situation.
You integrate Google Analytics on Puffer
AI. I don't think I did.
Can you even Can you just go to like
No, I don't think I I didn't do this on
our site.
duck try to poach you? I mean, unless
I've missed an email. No,
you need because you can track user
behavior.
Why do you like AI?
Uh, I mean, I can build stuff that
change the world from my chair here.
It's pretty cool. It's like fundamental
technological advancement of many many
things.
Did skip C render in training mode? Yes.
User have hard time find docs. I don't
think it'll actually tell you that.
I searched RL for like once yesterday
and now this pops up. That's funny.
I mean, it's cool to see that there's
that much exposure given that it's like
a pretty small channel. It's a niche
topic, so like there's not that much
content out there. But yeah, welcome.
I'm Joseph. I uh I stream all of my
research. So, you'll mostly see me
building new algorithms, new
environments, applying RL to new stuff,
all sorts of things. And then every so
often I uh write articles and things on
a little bit of the educational stuff
though it's mainly research.
Currently experimenting with a bunch of
RLMs. Each RM takes like 20 hours for
one seed. This is why you use Puffer
Lib. Actually, let me just give you a
quick little demo here. All right.
Let me just show you why I use Puffer
Lib.
Okay. Puffer Eval puffer pong.
This is going to load up a untrained
neural net. So this is a neural net that
has not been trained. It's very bad,
right? The blue one. It's losing. Yes.
Okay. Puffer. Train. Puffer pong.
Do the elevator music.
Just kidding. It's actually literally
already done training.
I just have to give it the latest model
which we just trained.
That's literally all there is to it.
So from uh however many hours it's
taking you to literally 5 seconds.
What algorithm?
It is an enhanced variant of PO that is
the product of our own research at
Puffer.
How many GPUs you got? That just ran on
my desktop here, which I'm also using
for streaming. So, one
technically like probably 08 GPUs if the
is taking like 20%.
And you can see that we have like 25
different environments on puffer.ai.
Not all of them train that fast, but
many of them do. How long would it take
for vision based? Uh, you'd be
bottlenecked by the rendering
essentially. But I think that
technically
you could probably I actually we have
done this. I think you can do it in a
few minutes if you really optimize, but
it's a fair bit harder.
How many GPUs do you have? Well, I have
20 overall. like in the background
there. You can see I have a whole bunch
of machines set up on those racks.
Hello.
Not much contents available about this
topic. Is there any reason why is it an
untapped topic? Uh it's really hard and
if you like if you check some of the
stuff on Puffer, you'll kind of see why.
But pretty much we've like right here
we've made the whole field a thousand
times faster in the last year.
For context, um my PhD is in multi-agent
reinforcement learning. I've done a lot
of work on speeding up reinforcement
learning, uh different environments,
different tools, things like that. And
it's really only been since I graduated
uh that I've been able to fully build
this stuff. And I essentially like I had
to rewrite the entire stack of
reinforcement learning to make all this
work. And before I did that, like if you
look at any of the other libraries,
everything was just really really slow.
It was kind of hard to get meaningful
results. Uh as the other fellow said
here, it was taking like forever to do
any basic experiments.
Now you're just bragging. I mean 20 GPUs
is not a lot for research standards.
Side of RL is a nightmare. How many
seeds? How many eval? Not to mention
hyper prams. We've fixed a lot of that.
What if I'm making a new novel algorithm
and I want to benchmark against DQN on a
bunch of M? How does Puffer there help
there? So, have you seen Clean RL?
Puffer is not that much more
complicated. You'd basically just take
our trainer, you'd like remove the 200
lines of code that are actually PO and
you would add your algorithm there and
then you would test across those two
things
in practice. So, Pufferlib doesn't work
like other libraries, right? There are a
lot of libraries that are devoted to
just having all the algorithms. The
thing is they're all really slow and
they're all really bad. But that's not
what we do. We have our own algorithm
that is just the fastest and the best.
And uh we like as we develop more stuff
on it, we test versus the old version of
that algorithm to see if things have
improved.
What was your bachelor's? Computer
science, AI, same thing. I'm mainly
using SP3 for everything. Okay, so
Huffer lib is going to be both simpler
and a thousand times faster.
It's like actually download it and try
it. You can pip install it and you can
literally confirm for yourself in like
two minutes.
Even clean RL is slow. Yes. So clean RL
is also slow. You can think of puffer
lib as clean RL but fast while trying to
keep things as simple as possible.
Understanding that of course it has to
be a little bit more complicated in
order to make it a thousand times faster
and support all the environments and all
that.
Clean RL is awesome. Uh it's really
really nice overall but yeah we we just
had to make it fast is all
your algorithm better be a good one.
I'll be experiment
SP3 has been a nightmare. My use case is
to test my novel algorithm. Yeah. So I
would just like go check puffer lab,
right? Pick some environments, run
baselines, and then just make a fork and
just do your algorithm there. Like the
code is really not that bad. Let me show
you. It's a heck of a lot easier than
SP3. I can guarantee you that.
Okay, this is our entire trainer. It's a
thousand lines.
Uh the only actual relevant code for
training is like the first maybe three
or 400 lines.
That's pretty much it.
This is a standard PO implementation
except that we have our know our
innovations on top of it. So we've got
this prioritize replay thing. We've got
custom advantage function. A few other
small differences.
And then here's our eval loop.
There's some extra lines in here because
we do a bunch of profiling. You can make
sure that everything is fast and like we
have some speed optimizations.
But
we really really work hard to keep it
simple. And I can guarantee you 100%
that you will not find anything anywhere
close to this speed uh or any like
anything close to this speed that's
anywhere near as simple. Or heck, you
won't find anything anywhere near this
fast in general. Like this is faster
than most of the Jacks repos by a factor
of three or four in literally PyTorch
eager mode.
I mean, you can see all the different
agents that we've trained on here. Like
Breakout, this trained in 30 seconds,
beats the game.
We've got Snake. This trains in like a
minute.
plays snake with a whole bunch of
snakes.
We've got drone flying. This trains in
30 seconds.
Pretty much works out of the box as
well, which is not a thing you see in
RL.
Probably replace my algorithm with PO
and try to run like 100 seeds.
Yeah. So, it's so our it's not quite PO.
Ours is better than PO. It's going to be
substantially more stable.
um
you can absolutely do 100 seeds. We've
actually gotten it to the point where
like most of our stuff is very very
consistent. There really isn't that much
per seed variance at all for almost all
the environments. And we have like
built-in hyperprem tuning. Welcome
Kovac.
list is impressive. Does really need a
good step function with rewards and
puffer handles LSTM and PO? Yep.
And it not only handles it, it handles
it in a way that's very transparent like
the entire training core of Puffer,
right? It's about a thousand lines for
the train file. We have some default
models that we use. So like few hundred
lines worth of default models if you
want. And then there's like I think
maybe 500 lines of ve of relevant code
for vectorization and that is it. That
is the entire stack. So it's like all of
reinforcement learning is maybe 2,000
lines.
Doesn't have to be longer.
Does Puffer support continuous action
spaces? Absolutely.
Really inspiring work. Hope to meet you
at at an AAR next year. A star.
next year or so I will be at RLC in a
few weeks
I don't know Aar
different conference I know it's a
search algorithm there conference called
AAR
I do meet up with people I will be in
Palo Alto in a few weeks followed by RLC
and I'll be back in Palo Alto for a
I did I've been doing less conferences
lately. Like I don't think I'm going to
do Nurups this year cuz uh last year
Nurups nearly killed me.
Uh, I spent like five days in the
hospital, lost 18 pounds with pneumonia.
I'm still not recovered from that.
Sucks.
Uh, so I will be considering whether I
do big conferences for a little bit,
but I will be at RLC.
Ow.
[ __ ] just pneumonia, man. It sucks. I
was in like ludicrously good physical
shape as well.
Like literally, I went to that
conference having come off of run a 50k
and then hit a like a few weeks after
that hit a thousand powerlifting total
and then after that I hit like a pretty
decent 5k time and then it just freaking
Yeah, it's rough.
Open review for NAS last Nurup
submission.
Was it the Was it the neural MMO? The
300? No. What was it? Was it the puffer
lib rejected one?
Underappreciated. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's
just Academia does not appreciate this
type of stuff. It's It's very
ridiculous. But hey, it's fine. No, we
will solve things. They will not.
Yeah, it sucks. And I've kind of like in
trying to train back, like in the
process of trying to train to like get
my old fitness back, I've kind of gotten
a bunch of injuries. So, it's like now I
can't even really train properly, which
sucks. So, I'm working on all that
stuff, but I definitely don't want to
expose myself to giant ass conference
again if I can avoid it for a little
bit.
until I hurt my shoulder a month ago. I
had at least I'd gotten my pressing
strength pretty much back and uh my
deadlift is kind of closeish to back
where it used to be, I think. Though I
haven't really tested a 1 RM lately. Um
but everything else kind of just sucks.
2:30 here in India. Catch your next
stream. Thank you very much for dropping
by. I saw a comment environment DM
control does not support an old commit
buried. You asked if I supported
continuous action space. The answer is
yes. Uh can we add deep mind control?
Yes. If you look at any of the other
thirdparty binding files, they're like
super short and super easy. For the most
part, they kind of just work. Um, we
haven't used deep mind control in a
while because nobody's asked for it
really. But yeah, you can absolutely do
that. It's you might have to like make a
fiveline change or whatever to make sure
the latest version is found.
But like we support continuous actions
and we mostly have a bunch of bindings
for thirdparty environments. It's very
very easy to add your own third party
bindings for stuff we don't
like. You don't have to do anything
special really to make stuff work with
Puffer Lib. Like we have one line
puffer.
gymnasium puffer envelope.
No support cuz yeah, that comment is
super old. We do have we do have
continuous action space support.
Yeah, we do have continuous action space
support and we have we have it working
on several different environments.
Heck, I literally posted this here. I
posted this yesterday.
Where is it?
Yeah, here you go. This is continuous
action spaces.
see the drone M. Oh, yeah, Finn. So, I
did that. I did that. Uh Finn uh Finn
and Sam made the original drone M. So,
yeah, we have a really cool new demo for
uh drones now. It does more than just
flag. Like, it can follow targets. It
can do a bunch of different formations.
And I came up with some like nice
structured rewards for all of it as
well.
Did I get a chance to look at my
question? Which one? Oh, the giant list
of them. It looks like you pretty much
want like a full guide to a ton of
stuff, right?
Yeah. So, I'm going to add some
material. I'm doing both, right? I'm
going to add There's a lot of material I
got to add.
Like the thing is that like
you're basically asking a whole bunch of
questions on how to do stuff without
asking how to understand any of the
fundamentals, right? I can't really like
I can't give you a robust template for
how to do stuff that doesn't involve at
least some level of understanding of the
fundamentals.
Does that make sense?
Section of required environment fields.
Nice.
Uh that's part of the template, isn't
it?
We have it like commented like you know
required required like you know make
sure you do this this way etc etc.
The intent is that so you can copy the
template and then when you start editing
stuff you know what not to edit or like
what to keep.
Yeah. So that's like API documentation
basically about how the thing works
which we will include in the uh writing
your own environment.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to add
I'm going to add that to the docs page,
right? And then that's going to be one
of the first things that like this sends
you to
Okay. How to understand an RL problem is
going to basically what I'm trying to do
mag is I'm trying to sort of get you to
build stuff and then slowly pull in
resources. Like here it's you're going
to build a very simple environment.
Okay, you're going to read some docs.
You're going to build a very simple
environment. Then you're going to read a
blog post and a couple other things and
you're going to like train a different
environment. And then you're going to
build something a little bit more
complex and read a little bit more,
etc., etc.
I've used Wi and Neptune, but compared
your work sufficiently, my intuition
would slow and bottleneck. How do you
handle logging millions of steps per
second? Because you don't add you don't
log every data point like you're you're
logging
What would it even be on average? I
think for Breakout, you're probably
logging like one point every several
million steps.
logging over epochs. Uh us well it
depends.
It's usually you log like once every
maybe every few epochs I believe or it's
not every few epochs. I think it's time
based. You log a like if it's been a
certain amount of time since you logged
the last point and there's data
available then you log it.
But like a lot of stuff is averaged,
right? you're not even going to get the
million log points into the trainer to
then average and log to wand B. Like
there's already averaging that's
happened before that in C.
So like there millions of log points in
C. They've they're aggregated literally
as you create them in C and then the
compressed versions are sent up to the
main trainer and then you have to like
average a relatively smaller number of
points across that. So, we've kind of
done we've done efficiency at very many
different layers for you. The code's not
that complicated and there's not that
much of it.
Yeah, this is a huge jump to reading
your first paper here.
I think you should build something.
in making
successful contributing. So going
through your docs now M will probably be
an OD cyst. Do you have other M built
numerical integration? You say the end
will be an OD cyst. What do you mean
that the environment will be an OD
system?
Like are you trying to do something like
neural odes or like what what are you
doing?
is a nonlinear physics system.
So step is often integrating the OD is
an initial value problem from zero to
get to the next step. Why is it
integrating from zero to t? I guess you
mean zero to dt.
I don't know if you have a specific
solver that you want to have or you just
want to like implement RK4 and see um is
there like a basic like RK4 and C
want to implement that would actually be
very useful to us like if you wanted to
actually like do something like this and
like make it work in the context of an
RL environment we would be very happy
with that.
We actually we really really like when
people uh with experience in other
domains come in and do stuff that's not
just games. Like our goal ultimately is
to really advance a ton of areas of
science. We suggest games because like
most people that come in don't have
experience in another branch of science
and games are like really easily
interpretable but that is actually the
highest value thing for us.
Yeah, I would just like from what I
know, I would just do like a basic RK4.
You can always do like an energy
estimation to see if it's stable, right?
If you're doing like I don't know some
sort of physical system, you can just
like can track energy to make sure it's
stable. Just develop the ENV as a
standalone in C according to our format.
If you follow the guide,
we suggest you kind of implement
everything in C first, just in the way
that we do it. Make sure it works as a
standalone like environment in C that
you can interact with and see the
dynamics working. And then you just plug
it into our RL
DOP
5. I don't know how good. Well, it
depends on your uh it depends on how
many steps of integration you have to
take, right?
RK4 is super fast, isn't it?
Okay.
It depends how many steps you have to
take, doesn't it?
Here's Dockery. C.
Uh, this is gigantic, though. It really
shouldn't be this long for an
integration method.
Oh, it's got a whole bunch of features
and annoying things.
I hope it's not this fancy.
If it is, if it ends up being something
this complicated, I would just start
with RK4 and see if that's good enough.
RK with higher AC accuracy. Okay. Well,
I just don't know how complicated the
implementation is by comparison or if it
has uh higher comp like compute
complexity, right?
So, the key thing to know in RL, right,
is simulation speed is absolutely king.
So, if you can get your simulation to
run at like millions of steps per
second, you're usually like you're
golden because you can just train on
unlimited data at that point. So, as
long as you have a stable system that
runs fast, you're usually good.
I would definitely start with something
simple, though, because as I'm writing
in my guide right now, the price of
complexity and reinforcement learning is
very, very high. Errors are very
difficult to catch because the agent
can't tell you that its data is wrong,
right? Or that some corruption is
happening
and it's just going to like not behave
as well as it should for some reason.
What if you have a few different types
of agents that need to train models for?
Also, what if you want an agent to able
to take an action every 100 steps?
Why would you do that?
So, if you have a few different types of
agents that need to change, you can
usually just train one model. I've done
this all the time, it's fine. Long as
you can make the obs and action spaces
match kind of fine.
Uh,
if you want an agent to take an action
every 100 steps, it's probably going to
be pretty slow. I don't know why you
would do that, but you can. It's just
that the step function takes the action
and then it updates the end a 100 times
in a loop, right?
You just better have fa fast dynamics if
you want to do that.
You're simulating an economy. We have
manufactured warehousing storefronts.
Manufactur just decides once to see make
RL is not a fun thing to do in a low
data regime.
So, if you're if you have a sim that
runs really really fast,
you can do this. But if you're going to
get like if you're not going to get that
much data on the like results of your
actions and it's going to be really
delayed feedback at that, it's not going
to be a fun time.
Use RL for high data regime problems.
And if your problem isn't high data
regime, ask how you can make it such
right. Make it so.
Is it fair to say if you had a system
where you had to control 10 gauges,
build a model with all the gauge
chaining options the action space
rather than trying to make each gauge an
agent? S
it's just a box of 10 or a
multi-discreet with 10 options.
What's the difference between vecums and
mnumms?
So env is in a single threat. So it's
only this case for ocean. So only our
like RC environments do it this way. Um
env tells you how many copies a single
process is going to simulate. uh because
the individual Python class can actually
create like 4,000 environments or
whatever sometimes. Okay. And then the
vecum m is going to tell you how many
processes. Instead of spawning 8,000
processes with one environment each,
you're going to spawn like eight with
1024 environments each.
We have other ways of doing this as well
for like slower environments with serial
cuz like you can technically you can
technically do the same thing a bit
differently but this is the fast way of
doing Yeah.
I will uh I think this is probably going
to be like a 10parter, like a 10
section.
Let me just see if I can write these
real quick.
This is going to be like here like uh
buffer algo article etc.
Then this is
It's going to be something like this, I
believe.
And this is pretty well the the full
path to becoming a uh a competent
researcher.
Obviously, like you have to repeat the
last few of these several times,
but this is quite good, I'd say,
overall.
Okay. Uh, it is 5th of July.
Huh. Kind of cool. So, apparently AI
training computer benches are going to
qualify as R&D. That is very nice.
That was a whole bunch of writing.
Usually there will be experiments and
research around here, but I figured that
I would uh work on something for you
guys. Need to finish this. Need to
update the docs, the extras that we
discussed. Uh this is well on its way
though. I would say this is very well on
its way. We'll have this. We'll have the
programming and ML guide. We have all
the other articles I wrote for 30 and
Spencer wrote like all the different
things. We've actually we've got a
pretty dang good base of content. We'll
just have to figure out sort of how I
want to organize it and what things are
going to go on the website and all that.
Okay. Uh thank you for tuning in folks.
I'm going to dinner.
You want to support all this work for
free?
Just star the repo. really helps.
Get involved by joining the Discord.
It's free. It's just freely available.
There's no invite link. I mean, no
invite code, just link. And follow me on
X for more. Thank you and I will see